to make things happen he's the one  realizing okay he doesn't want to play a  waiting game forever  but he is the one making the decisions  for example when to open things up  when to go for the bishop for nitrate  those are difficult decisions to make  magnus is saying you make the decisions  i'm just going to play quickly  and uh magnus is going to wait until the  clock stick down and then he'll start  putting on some pressure making some  threats and okay magnus  just having some snacks like i thought i  thought he choked for a second though  [Laughter]  alireza to actually come up with a  decision as to what he's going to do  we do have a quiz of the day where we're  asking which player do you think  is a secret crypto millionaire and why  and philippe's grandmother says that  they think that judith poger is secretly